[MUSIC PLAYING]
I grew up in New York City.
The streets were paved
with different colors
of broken glass.
Our bikes would
catch flats a lot.
But it was the
terrain of champions.
Making music and rhymes was
extremely therapeutic for what
I was seeing in the streets.
While Hip-Hop was
always truthful,
it uncovered the ugliness
in American society
from the man on the ground.
I'm going to create a brand
new song just for MasterClass.
You'll see my writing
process in real-time.
(RAPPING) Yeah, test one, two.
Big Nas, old money, new money.
I'll be teaching you how
to find your inspiration,
find your flow--
(RAPPING) Me, myself, I'm
the illest alive.
--and how to turn your life
experiences into music.
(RAPPING) I hear my calling heart
pounding out my chest.
As a young man, my raps
were about me still
maintaining my sanity
on a beautiful level
in this ugly world.
You are the one that
can change your reality
and uplift the art of rhyming
by being brave and bold enough
to try to do something
that hasn't been done.
(RAPPING) I've got more styles and more
flows, plus I'm much flyer.
I got more--
Go into a quiet room,
buckle your seatbelt,
and get ready for this ride.
(RAPPING) We can light up.
I'm Nas, and this
is MasterClass.